what's up
guys bang bang it is lunch money time
woo woo
we're together today well while she's
trying to get rich for us let's try to
get her lunch money right if you ain't
wearing black
you're wrong i got black on you got
black on uh that person over there
doesn't have black on that's fine
but don't forget that lunch money's not
sponsored by block five block five has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto in their crypto exchange you can
deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account or you
can get a usd loan against your crypto
collateral go get a block fi account you
can also then get on the wait list for
the credit card that will pay you
bitcoin rewards
go to blackfy.com
what's the first topic first topic
is bitcoin that's what i imagine that
lady back there is doing
being like you mean you cat calling
her no when i walked out of the shower
today i was naked for a minute and i
just she was like i'm not sure that
happened guys
okay european no
how am i supposed to talk about serious
things come on let's be serious
european central bank president
christine lagarde called on wednesday
for
global regulation of bitcoin saying the
digital currency
had been used for money laundering
activities in some instances
and that any loopholes needed to be
closed somebody wrote about this this
morning
tell us i actually saved one detail not
in the analysis just for the lunch money
crew because i figured you guys would
appreciate this
the irony of christine lagarde saying
that people are doing
funny business with bitcoin funny
business is that christine lagarde
convicted of criminal charges
what for funny business when was she
when she was i believe the
french finance minister we'll look right
now
she was convicted over her role in a
controversial payment to a businessman
so the euros so the funny business
that we should be talking about is how
is the ecb
president a former convicted
and a quarterback convicted of financial
negligence guys this is
crazy news nobody talks about that i
didn't write about it this morning i'll
save that detail just for you guys
but the funny business we should be
talking about is that the ecb president
did a lot of funny business in the past
how many times do you want to say funny
business
i just i just love this i love it okay
we're going to talk about people who are
doing bad things
with bitcoin but we're not going to talk
about you and the bad things you've been
doing with fiat currency by the way
bitcoin in the in the new york times one
percent or less
are illicit transactions it's less than
fiat where over two trillion dollars a
year
is being money laundered alone and
bitcoin is more regulated than all the
other currencies i wrote about this
morning gorillapop letter.com
but i just wanted to make sure i saved
one important detail for my lunch money
crew
and that is that christine lagarde
everyone forgets but
i remember i got a good memory i've been
telling you i remember everything
go ahead god what else do you remember
okay so
so speaking of bitcoin of the existing
18.5 million bitcoin which is around 20
currently worth around 140 billion
appear to be in lost or otherwise
stranded wallets according to data firm
chain analysis
and there's many people who are locked
out of their bitcoin fortunes as a
result of lost or forgotten keys
they have been forced to watch helpless
as the price has risen and fallen
sharply unable to cash in
on their digital wealth let me tell you
something i remember reading a similar
article in 2017 2017 was the last time
yeah
and um and there were people who like
literally were tr and this is when it
hit
20k people were doing hypnosis to try to
remember their
passwords isn't that ridiculous all i'm
gonna say
is that it ain't twenty percent uh it's
it's probably
over ten percent i believe that but
twenty percent's pretty big number that
one in five
wallets that seems a little high what is
likely
happening is they're trying to
triangulate based on uh if things
haven't moved from very early on
i know a lot a lot of early bitcoiners
they ain't moving anything you couldn't
pay them for their bitcoin
it's literally priceless and so they may
be getting caught up and people like oh
that is a
stranded wallet but it ain't stranded
you know what's funny every single
article that i read that says
uh this has made bitcoin popular with
criminals
who can use the money without revealing
their identity i really hope that every
time a reporter writes about
cash says uh cash is popular with
criminals who can use the money without
revealing their identity
of course it's so funny because you're
writing about everything is used for
with
criminals use everything guys they use
facebook they use twitter they use
uh a refrigerator they use everything
you should tweet this
no i'm good i i love that you're
becoming a bitcoin you're starting
to see you're getting an orange pill no
i'm not getting orange filled i just
know as
a reporter when you mention details like
that
you're mentioning it for a reason where
you would never mention it when you're
talking about regular money
i don't know whatever of course facts of
course everyone's got a narrative
they're all biased
you know who else okay yeah what were we
gonna say
you know who else is uh using
is buying bitcoin institutions and jb
morgan
so every time you write about jp morgan
you should say that they're using
money that criminals use too well that's
the us dollar they like
that too all the banks like to launch
anyway okay that's my tiny
little nugget i like the polina rants
let's get let's get more of those
put my lime green glasses on
it's not a cat calling her no she's cat
calling me i never thought i'd be
jealous of a poster
okay come on okay
so this is new so airbnb is canceling
and blocking future reservations in
washington dc
metro area during the week of
president-elect joe biden's inauguration
guests who had reserved a place will be
refunded in full
it will also reimburse the hosts with
the money that would have been
so i'm kind of convinced hold on a
second so the idea that you pay on both
sides
no no no but the idea is to cancel it
because there might be
armed protests correct no
here's the deal everyone who was saying
oh
people are getting de-platformed because
they violated the terms of service like
these people
i mean what if they didn't what did they
do wrong what if you got a business
what are you a business meeting that's
that was my question what if i as a
regular person who is not partaking at
any protests
and going to dc in an airbnb they cancel
it
by the way remember just remember that
all
all this means this is within their
right they're allowed to do this by the
way
that's part of american democracy we
should celebrate the fact that they have
the right to do this
but the fact that they're doing it shows
that these businesses
are monopolistic and they're going to
get decentralized the fact that they
literally are canceling and forcing
their politics on their customers
is garbage you literally you didn't
violate anything you signed us
you signed up for terms of service i
just you didn't do anything wrong
and now they're saying you cannot use
our service well but i think it's
interesting because okay so the idea is
to prevent people from protesting or
whatever it is
which is kind of stifling it but anyway
so that's the idea
but but those people are just
i don't like it's kind of like you can't
stop a criminal from doing criminal
activities
i'll take it one even further so they're
just gonna book a hotel
i'll take it even further airbnb is
anti-democracy
the most democratic thing you can do in
the united states is protest
it's your it is your it is your right
again this might be
our like i said hold on a second i said
the same thing
when social justice uh protests were
going on i said the same thing about the
political
uh protest i'll say it about every
protest he loves a good protest if you
have a cause that you care about that
you feel like
is strongly enough that you want to go
protest even if i disagree with you
go protest that is your right as an
american citizen that is your individual
freedom and liberty go
protest but when they try to stop you
now they are harming democracy so
that's what they're doing they're
intentionally saying we're going to
cancel all of this
so that people don't go protest that's
their reasoning so i think it's
interest i think there's going to be
like case studies on this
um in these business decisions are that
are being made
my worry is that a lot of these
decisions are being made really
fast um and
there's not a ton of like hold on guys
like let's
what precedent does this set for the
future
right um but anyway regardless whatever
airbnb decides i think those people they
are trying to prevent from doing what
they're gonna do
they're just going to go on vrbo or
whatever
or hotels in dc it's just uh
it's so interesting but okay i'm done
are you mad today no i think i'm like
i'm like fired up oh yesterday i told
him that
if we moved to miami miami paulina's
gonna come out and he was like oh god
anyway no actually what she said was
policita
and i said i'm gonna go get i'm gonna go
to the grocery store and i'll see you
later you just calm down
come on okay visa has ended
what are you doing i'm rolling my eyes
so everybody can see that that's really
i don't even know what that is that's
like zombie crap
okay she's looking at me
visa has ended its talks with
silicon valley startup plaid this was
this is crazy i wrote about this at the
time um
but but basically the department of
justice filed an anti-trust lawsuit on
grounds that with limit competition the
payments industry
i'm sure mastercard is loving this but
um
the deal about a year ago visa announced
that it planned to acquire platinum a
deal worth 5.3
billion dollars and now
and now plaid i do say pachala
the other day because like you say a lot
but i was like no i don't i think i do
but that's code for i was right guys i
think it's because i got nine hours of
sleep
last night um but the idea is now plaid
stop rolling your eyes now plaid has the
opportunity to maybe do a spec or go
public or you know do whatever it's
gonna do growth investors are swarming
they are oh are they yeah chamoth and
bill ackman are
sharing all kinds of memes on the
internet i saw that what was the snake
with the plant
the snake with the tulip that chamoth
tweeted does anybody know
go look in your hylogrific uh
i thought it was a spec i thought that
was the way he was alluding to but the
snake and the tulip what's the next
topic okay
if anybody has answers for me put it in
the comments
signal so brian acton
who he basically built and developed
whatsapp who which was then sold to
facebook
he's now saying that the ongoing outrage
over what facebook has done to the
messaging service he helped build is
driving people to his latest project
which is signal tell us about signal
signal is what whatsapp should have been
it's that easy it's a messaging app it's
fully end-to-end encryption
and it's privacy centric dangle [ __ ]
with your data that's
it it's pretty simple but uh
they somehow meaning whatsapp
can't help themselves they want to
monetize they want to do all this
craziness
they're getting people to sign this new
terms of service
it's pushing people's signal signal for
the win
i i used to use signal when i was a
reporter now i'm like literally don't
talk to me
okay encrypted not encrypted don't talk
to me okay
can i take that advice
no you don't talk to me i talk to you
okay uh ask lunch money
ask bothering the hell out of me all day
long
ask ellen in the comments uh
narrates twitter to me she like looks
through her twitter feed and then just
tells me
hey did you see this two seconds like
hey did you see this
i have twitter too i see it first
go ahead ask lunch money hashtag ask
ellen in the comments
this is one of my favorite lunch money
viewers
her name is 13 hails she said
hi pomp and paulina thanks for all the
fantastic information you give please
keep it coming
also you two are so cute i think she
just met me and my friend right here
my question is when a person has saved a
security fund
what's the best account or way to hold
it especially in light of inflation
six thousand dollars today won't be six
thousand dollars next week or next year
that's right but for me personally
i still have a savings fund with
fiat dollars just in case
anything ever happens you still have
your
fund for a rainy day
yeah your rainy day fund you should just
put it in a savings account
hopefully you can get a little bit of
interest on it to mitigate some of the
damages of inflation
but i wouldn't worry too much about uh
trying to get a great return on it it's
there for safety not necessarily
upside potential so let's say that you
said hey i need six thousand dollars
you know it's three months of expenses
um i'm gonna just put
it here and i'm gonna leave it and sure
it's gonna lose purchasing power
uh but maybe in the future like actually
i need 6 500 or 7 000
in there you can put a little bit more
in but i just wouldn't worry so much
about driving a return as much as i
would making sure that you have
liquidity
so liquidity trumps the the return there
yeah i also what i do is i
set like a certain amount of money to go
from my bank account to my savings
account every month
so that way you're you kind of like set
it and forget it um you're not
have to think about it every month in
life okay brent kt
another great lunch money viewer uh when
building an audience and honing your
writing skills do you see more value in
your name as your brand
or anonymity suit and not pseudonymity
specifically in the early stages
okay so i have an interesting take on
this i say
if you use your name it's good because
it um
it allows you to be authentic and when
when you're real
it shines through and the people reading
it and consuming it will be like oh yeah
that's her
that's like only her like she is like no
one else
so it helps build your brand that way
james cleo recently talked about why he
built
his brand under his own name it's
because it gave him
uh flexibility to write about whatever
he wanted and he wasn't just pigeonholed
into writing about habits
if he wanted to write about investing he
could do that too under his own name
but if you are working somewhere
and maybe they're not allowing you to
have something on the side or write
about whatever i think you could go
anonymous
and then reveal yourself later but just
yeah that's what i think i wish that i
had done this all student anonymously
wait why yeah why it's weird because
like
i didn't just start thinking about that
till recently but like it'd be pretty
cool for no one to know who it was
why i don't know it's just like more
freedom that way
like as an individual you have the
freedom but i also think that i couldn't
have built
all of the distribution and audience if
i didn't use my real name
because of the trust element yeah so and
also like they're not gonna bring a suit
anonymous person
on to television or on to certain
podcasts things like that so like the
ability to really grow it
uh comes from using my own name i like
it
all right guys that's it go get
[ __ ] can we have a new signal i like
that
you do that and i'll just shut it off
later
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block live is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends